[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
people think they got you all figured
out
based on how you look
but it's not that simple
especially when it comes to me
um a little more
complex
sorry i almost killed you
ow
who's my good boy i had the perfect life
[Music]
until one day
all yours little guy everything changed
there's been
[Music]
now i know when you look at me you think
big you're ginormous i can't wait to
show you to the rest of the guys they're
gonna fertilize the yard you think scary
younger who are you i'm oona
[Music]
i'll take that what sucks to be you i am
not a fighting bull can you guys help me
out this is the beautiful horsey side
and that is the stinky bullseye have a
nice day smelling terrible high hoof
clouds
nina needs me i'm getting out of this
place and i'm not leaving anyone behind
best plan ever just do exactly what we
do
[Music]
maybe we don't do exactly as we do
everybody in hit it wait for me
i've been waiting for this
[Music]
straight shot through there have you
seen these hips
[Applause]
[Music]
look at the cute squirrels
[Music]
bye